hello there
to all you anti-racist reverse racists
and regular racists i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message
for today march 16
2021 this is the last
day to sign the gavin newsom recall it
wraps up tomorrow
we've already got it people over 2
million signatures that
horrific buffoon is being recalled
although they're going to try to stop it
and we're going to get to that in a
little bit but it's a very exciting day
because of that before we get to the
stories guys as always click that
subscribe button and that notification
bell so that maybe just maybe you'll see
our videos
in your youtube feed and uh we got three
stories for you today
uh and they're sort of all over the
place because i got into a fight with
bette midler that's how we're gonna
bring this show home today
but we're going to start uh with a
follow-up on what we covered yesterday
which i really think is is the story of
the week no matter what else happens
this week
this absolutely crazy story where the
washington post
two months later has in effect retracted
they didn't even call it a retraction
they called it a correction
but in effect they retracted that's what
it actually is but they're not calling
to retraction because that sounds scary
uh correction sounds like we didn't do
something as bad uh this story where
trump on that secretly recorded phone
call with the georgia secretary of state
uh where they made it sound like trump
was basically doing something illegal or
at least immoral
by trying to get the secretary of state
to find
votes well it was all a hoax it was all
a hoax surprise surprise more
more fine work from the blue and on
journalists and we're going to play a
video from grabby and media that's just
incredible it's a two-minute compilation
of just the way other outlets
then just repeat a hoax and it will sort
of show you how
a hoax spreads how bad ideas
and viruses and lies spread throughout
the system so we're going to start with
that
then we're going to talk about joy behar
uh on the view
because uh she said that antifa is just
an idea have we heard that before
from that old guy this president that's
not sure who he is or where he is
yeah i think we've heard that and then
finally uh we're gonna play a clip from
msnbc because gavin newsom
the governor who again is being recalled
very exciting
uh he was on msnbc with joy reid who's
just one of the worst people in all of
cable news
and he promised to replace dianne
feinstein if in fact she steps down
because she's like 140 years old
if she steps down he promised to give
that seat
to a black woman which sort of sounds
like racial quotas and perhaps systemic
racism and all that and then finally
this is sort of connected to that story
i got i tweeted something about newsome
and bette midler remember bette midler
from uh
well she was in first wives club she was
in that episode of seinfeld
win beneath my wings she went after me
on twitter i'm in a fight
with bette midler and we're gonna unpack
all of that before we get to it though
guys
i want to talk to you about raycon i've
got
their fine headphones right here and as
you know once a year i like to go off
the grid
for the month of august but as you can
imagine unplugging is easier said than
done and what about the
other 11 months of the year i still need
my time away from screens and devices
and fortunately
by putting in my new raycon wireless
earbuds these things fit
i found a way to rest my eyes without
missing the important content that i
need to do my job and live my best life
whether you're catching up on reuben
report episodes listening to the
audiobook version of don't burn this
book an excellent book by the way
or powering through your workout with a
pumped up playlist a pair of raycons in
your ears
can make all the difference there are no
dangling wires or stems
and raycons come in a range of stylish
colors and always with comfortable
in-ear fit for a more discreet look
raycons are built to perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction and bluetooth
that pairs quickly
and seamlessly and with enough battery
life for six hours of play time you can
unplug for a while the best part raycon
makes great sound accessible to everyone
with wireless earbuds starting at half
the price of other premium audio brands
raycon is offering 15 off all their
products for my listeners and here's
what you got to do to get it
go to buyrecon.comruben that's it you'll
get 15
off your entire raycon order so feel
free to grab a pair and a spare
that's 15 off at buy raycon
dot com slash reuben by raycon dot com
slash reuben and now back to me
all right guys so this washington post
story the reason i'm willing to say
here on tuesday that it's the story of
the week pretty much no matter what else
happens
is because so much of the framing of
everything we're dealing with right now
like the endless craziness
cancel culture [ __ ] politicians like
the whole thing
what what sits behind that is a media
that is just completely dishonest we now
have partisan activists pretending
to be journalists we have almost no
actual journalists as you know i always
have to
use air quotes when i when i say the
word journalist that is a real problem
we've got two or three
andy no i would put in there but there
aren't many they
and not only are they partisan they're
pretty much all partisan
to the left right we know that they're
pretty much all democrats have you read
any critical pieces of joe biden
anywhere since he became president right
every day it was orange hitler this that
the other thing for four years
now there's seemingly like no criticism
at all but okay
i think you guys all get that this
washington post story
is is just so crazy because not only did
they make up what became a massive
scandal and and basically was used also
as part of trump's second impeachment
remember the sham second impeachment we
had the first sham impeachment then they
did a second one that like
remember that like nobody even talks
about it they had this ridiculous
two-day sham impeachment that went
nowhere
well part of what he was charged with
actually included uh
evidence from this evidence from this
washington post story
in any event what's interesting to me
about this is not just that the media
makes up stuff and they use
uh anonymous sources and no one ever
gets fired or exposed or any of that
like the fix is in on all that i think
if you're watching this enough you get
my feelings on that and i suspect you're
probably with me on that
what's interesting about this story is
the way that a lie can start
and how it then works its way through
all of mainstream media
so grabian media put together this
two-minute clip
of well just watch people on cable news
and regular news just repeating what we
now know
is a complete lie another week another
call nbc news confirming that president
trump
called georgia's chief elections
investigator
to quote find the fraud saying that
official would be quote
a national hero as president trump
personally called
georgia's lead elections investigator
and demanded that person produce
evidence
which didn't exist and quote find the
fraud
adding that if they did so they would be
a quote national hero
the washington post reported yesterday
that president trump called a georgia
election
investigator and pressured him to quote
find the fraud
and president trump apparently pressured
an election investigator
to find the fraud again not the phone
call
out of georgia another one we now know
of
a second there's so much a second call
from president trump to georgia
officials about trying to overturn
the election he reportedly told
an elections investigator in cobb county
to quote find the fraud
and then that person would be a national
hero
trump making that call was essentially
interfering in an active investigation
when he asked the top investigator to
quote
find the fraud saying that that official
would be a quote
national hero if that person did so
there was a second call to another
elections official in your state
to quote find the fraud well i was
pleased to see
that uh this kind of pressuring of our
secretary of state was added to the
articles of impeachment
nbc news confirming a washington post
report revealing that president trump
placed a separate call to georgia
election officials pressuring them to
and i quote
find the fraud while trying to overturn
the results there
late last month the president called
george's lead elections
investigator urging them to quote find
the fraud this was first reported by the
washington post
now we are also learning of another call
first reported by the washington post
and confirmed by our colleague jason
morris that the president called one of
these
investigators in the state of georgia
who was investigating election fraud
and urged him to quote find the fraud
and also encouraging him that he would
become a national hero if
indeed he did find evidence of voter
fraud
boy that's an awful lot of mainstream
journalists repeating a completely
fabricated situation
you see how they do that so somebody
makes it up with an anonymous source
washington
post and then everybody you saw cnn you
saw hln you saw msnbc you saw
you know article titles from new york
times and all the usual suspects
is anyone going to be fired is anyone
going to retract anything else
are any of these people gonna mention on
twitter
that they really dropped the ball and
didn't do their own research and just
went off someone else's research
this is a this is a real problem and the
reason i wanted to cover it and the
reason i think it has the gravity that
it has is just think what they could do
to anyone when we talk about this this
cancel culture situation
just think how they could spread a lie
about
literally anybody you me
anyone that they could just make
something up an anonymous source
could place something in the washington
post or the new york times a source on
capitol hill
right like you can't write well now in a
college there's no standards anymore
but back in my day when we went to
college if i was writing a paper i
couldn't say a source on capitol hill
told me a source in the college library
bathroom told me this
no you'd have to actually source things
and link and you know at the end you'd
have an appendix and you'd have to
actually show where you got information
from
there's none of that in the media
anymore and when you see a massive lie
like this
and then when you think about how big
tech told us well we're gonna
we're gonna worry about election
misinformation and we're gonna delete
posts and we're gonna put warnings on
things that don't fit our narrative
but you know if things you know fit the
other narrative right
or not fit the other narrative things
just happen to be true
if things just happen to be true well
then
they're going to leak all through
everything and then when we find out
that they're not true
well there you go so i i think you guys
get it
like these there's something very
dangerous like there's actually a danger
now they've gone from being sort of
manipulative to actually dangerous and
it's like if they're caught in this
what else are these people going to be
caught in you know let's not forget that
joe biden
launched his campaign launched his
campaign
on that very fine people hoax right we
all know
that it was a hoax donald trump did not
say
after charlottesville that there are
very fine people on both sides meaning
that the nazis are good
and the people against the nazis are
equally good he condemned all of the
neo-nazis in the sentence before that
i've played it here you don't really see
it on
mainstream media he condemns them and
then he said there's very fine people on
both sides meaning of the debate about
taking down statues which of course is
true
but they let lies run through the system
and then for you guys watching this at
home and for everybody for me for
everybody
it's like man it's now on us to somehow
pilfer
some truth out of the endless sort of
cascade of [ __ ] that they make us
swim through
and that's tough man that is tough for
all of us and that's why i say we're in
a reality war there is a war going on
for your mind in essence
and and it is much harder once you take
that red pill and you see the truth and
you see that these people are liars
and their anonymous sources are usually
their dogs and they just
make up this nonsense no offense to
clyde some dogs are totally reliable but
you get my point
and when you see though that these are
usually just depressed alcoholic
partisan losers and that's what most
members of the media are at this point
well then it's on you to figure out
what's true and then and then of course
the tough part is you have to explain
that to friends and family otherwise
they think you're bananas
and that's tough work but i have nothing
better to do and
you know do you all right guys let's
talk about expressvpn real quick you
know if you supported trump
and watched how big tech shut him down
it's reasonable to think that any of us
might be next that's kind of what i'm
talking about here the locusts are like
religious zealots who continue their
crusade of censorship repression and
cancel culture
until every last voice of opposition has
been crushed sadly they've been
reinforced by the media and some of the
largest companies in the world man this
was the right head to do right now
that's right big tech and the far left
have formed an unholy alliance to track
censor and spy on us their fellow
americans there's never been a more
important time to protect our internet
activity
from bad actors and that's why i urge
everyone to get expressvpn
everything you search for watch or click
online can be tracked by big tech
companies
they can then match your activity to
your true identity using your device's
unique ip address when i switch on
expressvpn with my computer or phone my
ip address is masked by a secure
vpn server which makes it harder for
websites to identify me
the expressvpn app also encrypts my
network data to protect my sensitive
information from being compromised
plus you can use expressvpn on up to
five devices simultaneously
so your whole family can stay safe with
a single subscription what i like most
is how easy it is to use it just takes
one click to protect all your devices
literally one click it's green you're
good
that's why they're rated the number one
vpn by cnet and wired so stop handing
over your data to big tech companies and
their far left enablers in government
defend your rights with the vpn i trust
for online protection
visit expressvpn.com ruben that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
ruben to get your three extra months for
free go to expressvpn.comruben
to learn more and now back to me all
right so the view
you know this show with these shrieking
harpies uh that used to be actually
pretty decent if you watch the view
i would say about 15 years ago
when elizabeth hasselbeck was the same
conservative i was actually far more
lefty than her at the time but i thought
she was a respectable conservative and
even
before rosie o'donnell went completely
bananas and she was on there and it was
during
george w bush's presidency and they
would do hot topics
and they would really argue about things
but it could for the most part remained
respectful it sort of devolved
over time but there was like a plural a
plurality of views on the show barbara
walter set
up the show i mean i remember i remember
literally watching the first episode
of of the view it's got to be 20 years
ago and in it she did a little talk in
the intro
about how she wanted women of different
walks of life and different
different opinions to come together and
talk about things and that
that is a pretty good liberal idea right
the people who are different can talk
about ideas
and debate them and at first the show
actually was not just about politics it
was about all sorts of stuff but they
did the hot topics thing and that
and then as everything became more
political the show really just became
about politics they brought in whoopi
goldberg who i used to like and she's
become
sort of a crazy lefty and joy behar who
i loved
i used to love joy behar i lived about
three blocks from her on the upper west
in new york city i would see her on the
street we chat about comedy and
and i've interviewed her two or three
times on my old serious xm show years
ago
i just adored her and she was like a
sane liberal but
orange man bad and she just lost her
mind and went crazy as so many
lefties have um and here's a clip from
yesterday
on the view joy talking uh about antifa
and i think you'll see why we're playing
it right out there with his racism
there's no dog whistle for him you know
it's like i'm a racist
have a nice day you know what i mean i
guess you know it's funny when i was
watching this it's so aggravating to
listen to this idiot
i mean he and i are very different i'll
tell you this right now
if i was surrounded by people carrying
weapons uh
people erecting nooses a screaming hang
mike pence
bludgeoning a police officer to death i
might be a little scared
but ron no he's not scared of those
people he's scared of this fictitious
idea of antifa
a thing that doesn't even exist
okay so she's talking about republican
senator ron johnson
now okay yes he's racist i know that's
all you got he's racist he's racist he's
racist
but then this uh this comment at the end
antifa doesn't exist
well boy that that sounds sort of
familiar hmm
somebody's got to do something about
antifa and the left because this is not
a right-wing problem
yeah antifa is an idea not an
organization and i think at the end
there he said not malicious if i got
that part right he said not malicious
antifa's by the way been destroying
cities all over the united states for a
couple years now they've burned down
targets and pep boys
they've caused something like it's been
estimated about one to two billion
dollars worth of damage
over the last couple days they've been
burning down a federal courthouse in
portland you're not going to see that on
cnn or from blue and non-journalists
so why are they pushing the idea that
antifa is an idea why would they be
doing that
they're telling us not to see what we
can see right in front of our eyes you
may remember that video on msnbc
with journalist ali velshi standing in
front of a burning building as if a bomb
had gone off in fallujah talking about
how the protests are mostly
peaceful are you telling me they're
mostly peaceful i live here in los
angeles where many of our streets
are still boarded up and you know you've
got signs on them that say black lives
matter
which is sort of become like a hostage
situation i have to close my business
put a board on the door right black
lives matter otherwise
you're going to destroy my business but
that's how good you guys are like
so black lives matter and antifa have
melded into this sort of
this relationship made in hell it's
forged in hell
very it's very twisted but anyway this
this idea
that antifa is just an idea is a
terrible idea
and it is completely untrue but why
would they want you to think that
they want you to not be able to see what
you can see right in front of your eyes
so that they can keep lying to you about
everything
you know the election happened right the
the i voted for trump obviously i
supported trump and i wanted him to win
but you know after the election were
cities burning all over the place now
that does not diminish what happened
on january 6th it doesn't but were there
cities burning
all over the place no what do you think
would have happened if donald trump
would have won
there would have been cities burning all
over the place extended and by the way
there's
more burning cities coming because we
know what's going to happen in
minneapolis right after the george floyd
verdict so like this stuff is coming
they're telling us it's coming it's
still happening even though they got
good old joe why is there a federal
courthouse
being attacked on on a nightly basis in
portland right now
as we talked about the other day there's
an autonomous zone in minneapolis are we
a third world country or are we america
are we a nation of laws
or are we a nation where you can just do
whatever you want and burn things down
and take over streets
and destroy stories if your politics
sort of fall in line
with what the democrats want i think
that question is up for debate at the
moment because there is no clear answer
on it
anyway not good joy not good joy
not good joe joe and joy you got we
should have a sitcom
joe and joy where they battle an
imaginary antifa
or no we should have a sitcom where it's
joy behar
and and joe biden and they live together
on a street
in portland and they have to put up with
antifa every night but because they're
good
lefty liberals even as their building is
burning down they're going oh this is
just the idea
of our apartment burning down nice to
know you joy so
ridiculous all right so uh gavin newsom
who again is being recalled
hallelujah uh was on joy reid's show on
msnbc yesterday joy reed i would say is
probably
you know as bad as say don lemon and
some of the cnn people are joy reed is
just
absolutely the worst sort of partisan
terrible liar and fraud these these
again these are just not these are
clowns these are not people anyone
should be paying attention to
but joy reid uh had gavin newsom on and
she was talking about how
if dianne feinstein who was our senator
here who how old is dianne feinstein
named she's got to be in her late 80s
there's all these rumors that she has
cognitive problems i'm shocked the
democratic an old democrat
with cognitive problems that's so
strange um she's 87 years old and by the
way if i'm not mistaken
she's already filed to run again in a
couple years when she'll be 89 like
that's how insane
this is these people will not go away
they will not give up power
and just go away well anyway gavin
newsom who's the governor obviously here
in california and she
and feinstein is a senator here if she
was to step down the question was asked
by joy reid
would he replace her with a black
woman because that's what you should do
if you want to be a good workster let's
take a look okay we are out of time out
of time out of time i have to go to a
break but i have to there's a yes or no
answer that you could give me
uh if in fact dianne feinstein uh were
to retire
uh will you nominate an african-american
woman
um to restore the seat that kamala
harris is no longer in the united states
senate and do you have a name in mind
i have multiple names in mind
we have multiple names in mind and the
answer is yes
okay uh governor gavin newsom thank you
all right so let's just be clear here
she's a racist and he's a racist simple
as that
first off a seat is not owned by anyone
kamala harris does not own that seat
which by the way has been
replaced they already replaced that seat
but she doesn't own that seat any more
than dianne feinstein owns her seat
dianne feinstein happens to be a white
woman so then if you were replacing it
by race wouldn't you give it to a white
woman
these people are absolutely ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous this is counter
to everything that america is all about
okay
like you once you see it and i i know if
you're watching this you've seen it
already
but we need more people to see it the
idea that because
one black woman stepped down to become
vice president
then if another woman steps down we
should get a black woman to replace that
other black woman
what like it doesn't even make any sense
and how about
you're not going to believe this guys
how about you replace
feinstein if and when she steps down
with someone who's qualified
and you don't care if they're a white
woman or a black man
or anything else and by the way there'll
be plenty of people who are qualified of
every immutable characteristic combo
every idiotic intersectional idea that
you can come up with
we can find somebody who's qualified but
he's such a coward and a buffoon
yes i'll do that joy because i'm a good
wokester
god i can't wait to get rid of this
idiot but anyway speaking of gavin
newsom he is being recalled and the new
meme out there the new meme is that the
recall is being done by
far-right people it's a partisan
right-wing
evil conservative thing two million
people in california have signed it but
it's
it's a partisan right-wing thing you may
remember last week i read a tweet
from bernie sanders uh calling it a you
know it's a right wing
oh i got to do my bernie it's a right
wing thing that they're taking out
okay that's more i guess that's more
jackie mason than
bernie sanders it's a fine line the
right wing people
are trying to take out the thing okay so
anyway gavin newsom tweeted this so
let's let's put up gavin's tweet from
yesterday
and he said i won't be distracted by
this partisan republican recall but i
will
fight it there's too much at stake
getting californians vaccinated
our economy safely reopened and our kids
back to school
are simply too important to risk okay so
i just want to be clear again this thing
is not partisan
by any stretch of the matter i have been
to rallies i meet people that are mostly
democrats
they're mostly liberals they're mostly
non-political people
they're mostly restauranteurs who
suddenly have been mugged
by progressive reality by the way right
now it's a beautiful day as always here
in socal about 70 and not a cloud in the
sky
you still cannot go to the gym you still
cannot go to indoor dining
we have 25 outdoor dining or something i
don't think that anyone's really paying
attention to this anymore
well i guess i guess a certain set of
just
generic people are but but good people
aren't
insane people aren't um but anyway it's
so he's saying it's partisan right so
i retweeted him and here's my tweet and
i said
it isn't partisan it's democrats
liberals centrists
and just regular folks whose lives you
just lives you destroyed for political
purposes
as promised i will throw your retirement
party at
french laundry and then i link to the
video of the event that we did about two
weeks ago here in los angeles with the
reuben report locals community
where i got about a hundred real live
human beings to drink
and shake hands and eat food and smile
and talk to each other
and in case you missed it here it is hey
gavin newsom
dave rubin i know you know me man listen
we're doing an outdoor gathering here in
los angeles got about 100 people here
we're eating
we're drinking we're talking about stuff
and we got a nice lady who brought the
gavin newsome recall
and pretty much everyone has signed it
already so but we finally found a guy
this guy over here had not signed yet so
use my back
he's
anyway sending my best hope everything's
good up in
sacramento and look forward to seeing
you at your retirement party at french
laundry
all right so i will throw a retirement
party for the guy at french laundry i
realize that
i guess that sounds kind of like
smuggling elitist maybe we'll we'll
crowdfund it or something let's see if
we can raise like 100 grand and we'll
just get as many people
as can get there as possible although
maybe maybe we should just do it at in
and out that would probably
be better but here's where the story
gets interesting because i know just
telling you that gavin newsom is a fraud
and a buffoon isn't that's not that
interesting we all know that
it gets interesting when bette midler
hollywood star
actress singer bette midler gets
involved she retweeted me
and she wrote total bs don't listen to
this chump she's talking about me
these people are the same old prop 13
tax scolds
who don't want their taxes to pay for
your kids education
california schools went from number one
in the nation to number
to 47th after they got done spreading
their selfishness
throughout the u.s and then hashtag boo
greed now i responded quickly and i just
said enjoy you in first wives club
but i had to do a little googling
because i did not
hear about uh prop 13. i didn't know
about prop 13 so i wanted to see
maybe bette midler hollywood star woke
elitist
bette midler is making a good point so i
thought all right prop 13 boy i must
have missed that on you know i've
been here for a couple years i've voted
in all the elections since i moved here
in 2013. uh there's got to be
you know something that i need to know
well it turns out that prop 13 is from
1978
okay so she's angry at me over something
that happened in 1978 i was only two
years old i lived in brooklyn
at the time before it was hipster
brooklyn when it was og brooklyn
uh and here is from balopedia this is
what prop 13 is california proposition
13
the ballot initiative was designed to
require that properties be taxed at no
more than
one percent of their full cash value as
shown on the 1975-76 assessment roles
and limit annual increases of assessed
taxable value to the inflation rate or
two percent
whichever was less okay so in essence in
1978 when i was two years old living in
brooklyn
they passed something in california that
limited how much
the state could just arbitrarily decide
how much property taxes are you're not
going to believe this bet i'm 100
for that we also have ridiculously high
property taxes
in california some of the highest in the
united states and of course in la it's
some of the highest
in the state so high very it's very high
all around over here
also this is this is such a perfect
illustration of
what so many leftists think about
everything that only
if we just took enough money from you
people
right if we just took your money and put
it to the things that we want to put it
to
that thing that things will be better
and they love to throw money at things
so instead of
really thinking about well are our
students being educated properly
are we spending this money wisely it's
always about oh just throw more money at
it but then i thought okay
let's do a little further digging and
let's find out some information because
she's saying that
it's all sort of bottomed out over here
we've got a map of public school
spending per student right now look at
the map
take a look over there at the map
california spends
on average 12.5 thousand dollars
which is ranked 20th per student on
education
okay florida which spends less 9.3
is ranked third this is in performance
obviously
so meaning that in student performance
cal uh
florida spends about nine thousand per
student they're ranked third
california which spends three thousand
more about a quarter more
uh is ranked twentieth so it again they
just
they don't think anything through so not
only is it a proposition
from 42 years ago when i was a child a
proposition that i would have voted for
if i was an adult at the time because i
understand that you can't just raise
taxes
to make things better it always makes
things worse but also we did a little
further digging
and bette midler she's she wants your
money
if you live in california she wants your
money for her purposes uh she's worth
an estimated as of january 2021 250
million dollars
250 million dollars now i
you know i'm not one to tell someone
what they can do with their private
funds
but it seems to me she could take i
don't know say 200 million of that and
build some schools do do some good stuff
with that
and i'm pretty sure i'm not bette
midler's accountant and i'm not privy to
her
uh her documents but i'm pretty sure
that when she does her taxes she does
her taxes like every other sane person
which is you say to your accountant
don't do anything illegal but i'd love
to get a rebate check
you know keep it all across the t's dot
the eyes
but you know i don't want to pay a lot
in taxes but this is what they do they
virtue signal the [ __ ] out of everything
while pretending that they're
moral for wanting your money they've
actually made jealousy seem like a
virtue
and that is a problem so and and then i
was thinking about one other thing
related to this
putting aside like all the specifics
about education and the money and
everything else
this is if you want like a perfect
example of how wokeness
and how how modern leftism ruins
everything it's like
i have no problem with bette midler the
episode of seinfeld she's in is one of
my favorite episodes
i love the movie first wives club she's
been in some other stuff that i like
halloween comes around if hocus pocus is
on i'll watch hocus pocus
but now every time something comes on
that has bette midler in it i'm gonna
have to think oh there's that crazy lady
who called me a chump on twitter and
that is how the hyper politization of
everything that we have going on right
now
where these people it's like don't you
realize bette midler that half the
country at least doesn't agree with you
but only the lefties can get away with
it if gina carano dares
say something that is actually true what
happens to her she gets booted from
disney
but you can be a lefty in hollywood and
call half the country racists and chumps
and buffoons and deplorables
and you're good to go and that is why
what i'm interested in is people who
build things
and one of the very cool things that's
happening right now is we're seeing
conservatives start to build things as
you guys know uh
daley wire is going into business with
gina carano and she's gonna produce some
movies for them
they're doing a live studio show with
candace owens like that's pretty awesome
my guys at the blazer building all kinds
of cool things i like people who build
not just people who do and speaking of
people who build uh part two
of my interview with david sacks uh who
is a
huge bc guy from craft ventures and a
great guy and he's he's been really uh
an outspoken proponent of getting rid of
gavin newsom and he's
he's challenging i mean when you talk
about do and not just talk
he's been challenging the san francisco
d.a
to debate because i don't have to tell
you you guys already
know what's going on in san francisco
it's just an abject disaster
because of their d.a his name is chesa
bodine and of course we now have their
former d.a
down here george scott who's also being
recalled and they're trying to recall
chessa
as well there's a lot of interesting
things happening if you can see it you
just can't see it if you watch
mainstream media
uh anyway uh saks uh part two is
on youtube right now and of course the
full interview is already available
totally ad free at
rubenreport.locals.com
uh oh and then i will have a bonus
interview this week we are
doing a shorter bonus interview with
senator rand paul
they reached out to us he wanted to talk
to me and drop some info so we're gonna
do that excuse me i'm choking here we're
gonna do that on thursday
and uh for more if you wanna play along
and chat with me directly join us at
reubenreport.locals.com hope you enjoyed
the show everybody have a great day and
i'll see you tomorrow